you think you're an artist you just
divorced your sugar daddy you live in
SoHo you got priced out of Soho this is
where you're coming now you're gonna
take that money and you're gonna give it
to me and you're gonna rent this space
welcome back to another department do I
have a Cox apartment for you having no
smoking sign is if you need to be
reminded a bathroom with a toilet just
continues to run all day that's what it
sounds like sounds like everything's
running and dripping in this apartment
this is beautiful I won't even call this
apartment it's a loft they have a
bathroom in
[Music]
have a nice dripping faucet do you know
what your water bill is going to be
looking like okay the most disgusting
stove I've seen in a long time you have
a fridge that I I'm not opening that
fridge if I had a gloves maybe I would
open the fridge got some stairs to
nowhere just got some stairs this is a
nice Upstate Vibe honestly the upstairs
the bars on the Windows that's nice
that's nice